uh a minute earlier than usual but this
set the second derivative on arrival
rate seems to have calmed down
um so uh this is our final meeting of
the
50 years of satisfiability workshops um
it's almost the last meeting for the
sap program but we do have one further
meeting today at 11
uh o'clock in two and a half hours from
now i should say
uh which for a town hall wrap-up meeting
uh
and antonidas send some announcement out
to the pro program participants and
encourage you to come uh if you didn't
get a message and want to come just just
let me know we can drop you the link i
think the link for the meeting though is
not the same as the seminar link so you
should go to the link that's in and to
nina's
email message for that so i encourage
everyone to come to the town hall
wrap-up meeting after this
and then otherwise as i said this is the
final of the
workshops uh in the fit in the 50 years
of satisfiability sequence
and one of the themes both of the
workshop but of the whole sap program is
the interplay
between uh theory and
practice uh and so we actually are
ending with
two talks uh one by a person who's i
would
say is maybe more on the practical side
uh armin and the one who's more on the
theory side
but nonetheless i mean both people
contributed to both sides right both the
theory and the practice so armin has
done a lot of practical stat solving but
also contributed a lot to the theory
of stat solving especially as it
pertains to the practical
aspects and uh he's uh speaking today on
a personal history of practical
sad solving topic i'm really looking
forward to and
uh he's asked me i think he'll say it
again himself to
encourage interaction questions so for
this please
post to the chat window or just break in
and
speak up and we'll be happy to take um
interruptions
and uh otherwise armin please go ahead
thank you
okay thanks sam for for the introduction
and also thank you for for the
invitation
when i said yes um when sam invited me
um i knew that this would be a really
really really busy time
and then when i had to come up with a
topic for this talk like two weeks ago
i thought like um okay i almost have no
time but there's this thing i always
wanted to explain a little bit more
and that's actually this slide so this
slide is usually the slider end
with most of my invited or tutorial
talks on sat
um so if you have seen my two other
talks in this semester so like one was
four hours
in the boot camp and then there was
another one which was two hours
um then it ended with this slide
actually with a previous version of that
one
and now i have like slightly less than
than
one hour and what happened in these
other talks is usually that i i cannot
really go into this uh
history and it looks to me that um
well why not trying to like go through
some of these
um hopefully very interactively with you
um
would be a best fit for for this
workshop so so here's my personal start
solving history and of course i
apologize
if i if i miss anything else it should
say maybe
personal practical sets of in history of
course uh
and um if i miss some name uh
please uh i apologize um anyhow
uh so please interrupt me anytime so sam
will monitor the chat
and uh of course like for the panelist
i'd be happy to
to see you too but i'm also happy to
just answer your questions
uh through sam uh so we come back to
this slide at the very end again of this
uh talk so the talk doesn't have that
many slides and should have then
uh also plenty of time to go through
some of these points
um but um why uh do
i um actually do this and he's like four
or five slides like i did also
for the boot camp introduction talk well
uh this is a slide i did for my dean
once
but he wanted to know what i'm doing and
i just collected the slides at the
the medals we received for ourselves
overs
until 2015 and i took this picture
and maybe more interesting and more
reason
more more recent of course here is this
plot which
uh was done together with marine
uh so we took the sat competition 2020
benchmarks and then we're running it on
our cluster for 5000
seconds so one hour 23 minutes and
um what you see down here uh is here
this um
time uh so 5000 seconds here's one kind
of the time limit
and on the y-axis you see the number of
of soft instances
if you paid attention to start solving
history in particular on the practical
side so you will see that this is not a
cactus plot it's kind of a pector spot
where
where x and y axis are flipped uh and
like there are some who prefer that like
i i started to become one of those
uh so higher is better here so you solve
more benchmarks obviously
and what you see here this is this
legend here on the right and you see
also like here
this blue dot here is this oldest over
here
this was the oldest solo which won a
competition in this century so we have
had two competitions before in 1992
and one in in beijing and um
these are like those competitions which
happened uh
in the last 20 years and like maya so
here kisat here solved a huge number of
benchmarks compared at least to the
previous year's winners so last year
there was a version of
the year before so in 2019 there was a
version of
of maple um not by the original authors
actually this is already the second
generation of authors which
modified maple here and uh yeah
every year like uh last year there was a
maple version so there was a big
improvement in 2016
and this one you see this jump here
and uh yeah here's uh in 2014 my solo
one and also
in 2013 another version of it then there
were two glucose
solvers and so on so you see how here uh
on the right
um the solver is the winner of this
particular competition
a map to the number of solved instances
here on
on the left and i would claim this
shows a big improvement in in saat
solving
if you have attended us the talk from
holger last year
we're struggling a little bit in in how
to assess sort of the improvement of sub
but i think this this plot is convincing
um and um in particular for one reason
in 2016 the sub community in bordeaux
where this silver one and there were
lots of soul was very close to this one
we kind of were a little bit um
frustrated because we don't understand
like how to rank solvers anymore
but i think like this method here shows
some improvement i should also say
immediately
that there was last year actually two
seoul was right behind uh this winner
here which was my silver kisak
and um but they're not here on this plot
so there was just a big jump last year
in terms of sort of
um robustness and and solving capability
and um yeah so this triggered some
tweets and i explained this already in
the boot camp
yes yes so on your previous slide
actually it's two questions
uh first you mentioned there were two
other solvers that had a similar
improvement was it due to the same
techniques or different yes they were so
same interesting so it's like
interesting so they both put a local
search in it which actually i proposed
in 2019 already
and they also use this variant of target
phases both of them so this is crypto
minisot
and the version of maple like this maple
here but
with cca in our edit this came in second
and so all three
uh also category by the way now have
local searches over in it to sort of fix
faces and they all have some variant of
these target phases which i described
with matthias last year's post talk
you can go into that if you want but um
well that would be interesting but let
me ask my other question is
what if you ran the same types of tests
say on one of the early
sat programs they went back to say 2005
and ram all these software
this is of course of course i will do
this this is one of the parts i i'll
show you
six more of these actually so you see
lots of them actually
so we come to that and so so in some
sense i'm showing like cdfs which like
these community displacement functions
which um uh are reactions to like what
people ask me after i'm showing this the
first time so that's why
why i kind of anticipated this question
all right there's more questions or
should i
uh daniel posted a link
in the uh chat window to
one of your papers armin uh beer of
flurry pods 20 talk
yes exactly now again i have this window
which i can't get away
should have not clicked on this so i
move this up just a second
it doesn't go away maybe
last time what did i do so i clicked on
participant then the window shows up
yeah and then close it okay
great working again and
just sorry about that um okay now there
was a
um also some of you might have seen this
so this
so so we posted this uh or i posted this
with the help of mine on twitter
actually got quite some uh reactions to
that which was surprising
and like people were astonished that you
can solve this many variables so here's
like a distribution function
actually the the largest instance in the
sub competition has 700 million
variables
in the planning trade not here this is
the main track so this is quite
substantial and also like on the right
you see here
uh there's this uh issue by somebody
using cbmc to verify
deep neural networks and inside of this
verification they're using boolector one
one of our smt servers and in that
there's lingeling
by default like an old solar of mine and
this has a level limit of 2 to the power
27 what you see here
and then of course the scene crashes and
it's really amazing like
um how far they got actually they would
probably need like a
half a terabyte machine to actually run
this but
it turns out that actually people are
producing
larger and larger benchmarks and it's
really no
no joke what i'm doing here so android
shown is using bollector in the company
in uh
in the uk and he already also figured
out that yeah maybe sometimes you really
want to have like int max variables so
this is two billion variables
and now my sat solvers actually are
working with this uh large number of
variables so this was the erection then
of aina and
yeah so so you see here in the numbers
maybe this is interesting
so lingling has to the power seven
category has really hit max
uh keysight has currently two to the
power 28 which is like 256
million variables and i'm pretty sure if
i continue hacking sat solvers for a
while i will need to move to 64 bit
variables so more than 2 billion
variables
i think this is really amazing
so then of course we did the handbook
you must have seen this a couple of
times
i'm just showing this to sort of like
yeah i should show this so this is the
old handbook
we had this uh from 2009 and we had
these chapters
and and then there's a picture with
donald knuth donald knuth also got into
sat and he
he actually visited us here in linz gave
a nice talk
and and played the book origin
and and then uh he wrote this 300 page
section subsection or sub sub section of
the volume 4
and it's also only about a set um
and yeah here's the beginnings i'm
sharing these two that there's really
like 300 uh
pages of course half of them are
exercises so you should not it's not
like 150 pages of
real material but the exercises are
really tough so some of
our papers just turn into like a
two-line exercise
okay um then uh this year we're going to
have the second edition so this is of
course like
should should be mentioned when we talk
about the history of saatso
so these are seven new chapters and uh
you can read them so i'm not going
through that
uh now again and uh they were also
mentioned here in several talks in this
special um semester already
so this is how it looks uh actually i
haven't seen the physical version yet so
people keep asking
but i got an invoice yesterday so it
seems to be shipped
um and now i come to
um uh one variant of what um
um sam asks so this is another plot so
it's very similar to the other one
but it has 21 i think or like roughly 20
sat solvers the other one had just 13.
so it for instance has here
it's the same data as before uh it has
the grasp from 1997 so with the help of
i was able to to to get this working
because it's not really to port this old
c plus plus call to newer machines
uh the same is true to charade and most
people
um yeah actually this was a little bit
difficult because they had various
versions of this jeff and the hard disks
and some of them were compilable some
not so i have here one version which i
think
is consistent and you see it fails here
somehow
actually my first silver lima i
should tell you this history about that
one so i read this paper by
uh the friends from princeton by chaff
and i could not believe it so i don't
know whether how often this happened to
you in your career
so i would say uh at least half at most
half of
dozen times and this was one case i read
this paper and i couldn't believe what
they're what they're claiming okay
and my reaction was i had to um
implement this what they're saying and
of course i'm originally i failed
so i was never able to um get their
speed up but then at one point when the
source code became available it actually
was lint house version not this version
so
ninten with the z this is the z shaft so
this is sometimes called
m chaff or the original chef was called
just chef by musketeer this was the
sort of the source code of the original
paper which actually kind of was never
really published
uh was only available very briefly on
the internet so the one everybody was
doing afterwards with the version of
lintar
and uh only after like linda's version
came available i was able to fix some
issues actually related to
to uh unique implication points which is
actually an interesting current topic
yeah
i'm added some more we had a big step
forward here in
in 2005 with this uh this is kind of
uh the preprocessor i did with niklas am
together
with the mini sat um or they it was not
minnesota it was the predecessor of
miniset
and uh minisat was also here in this
competition but was worse than the
washington
with the satellite then the the next
minnesota years
they incorporated this pre-processing
insight so this is why
people improve then there's
cryptominisat like precocious of one of
my silver which won a competition
then there's kind of a period where
glucose was was leading
then um i came up with this um lingaling
and which had lots of this in processing
this was kind of the start of the in
processing phase
actually all the servers above here use
in processing not just pre-processing
but in processing you can
think of so pre-processing started here
in 2005
and then since 2013 all the winners have
improcessing in it and then i claim so
so
we came here also to a kind of a from
here right to a
a kind of a point where there was
progress but slow progress and then last
year we saw another big champ so you
maybe um one thing you can really see
here these jumps come
in maybe five-year distance and
we have seen them every five year and
and and furthermore
uh they're often combinations of
techniques which is also
of course difficult or not nice from a
scientific perspective perspective
right so when i explained today so that
the big jump here was due to kind of two
techniques
the same was true here for the for for
this jump from here to here because it
was the minister
implementation but also it has lots of
things which i could
explain uh plus the the pre-processing
okay and um yeah one thing
i also want to point out earlier in the
sub competition had uh had only like
in the very beginning closed source over
so this berkman here was never available
and there's a siege set solo for which
we don't have source code
and there's some intel solvers too
okay um armin
since no one else is asking a question
i'll jump in again but i hope someone
else will take up the slack for me
uh i just heard on monday a rumor that
minisat
was named minisat because of clause
clause minimization
i always thought that could well be but
i don't know because i have papers with
both
authors and uh i don't know so i should
ask nicolas
the class so nicolas and was the one who
invented this
minimization actually no mini set is
minimalistic sets
it's that yeah so in 2003 that was
the first version of mini set it
minimalistic set
ah okay yeah okay good that's what i
always thought but i heard this other
rumor
going around well it's also because it's
only nicholas silvanson invented this
minimization and it was later right this
was parallel
with our um satellite work here
which is with the niklas a and not with
nuclear servants
okay so so time-wise that's probably
right
all right um all time winners on the
side competition two in
the 2011 benchmarks there was kind of a
claim by by some
people i will not repeat the names in in
the post workshop
two years ago um that they were not
happy with
um how we do the the ranking and that
nothing changed since 2011 was one of
the sort of
like things put forward uh and before i
explain that note
so these are the same solvers but on the
2011 benchmarks
uh these here are way harder benchmarks
uh so so uh these are 400 benchmarks and
we're like solving 250
while while i'm sorry well these guys
here
uh they are from 292 right
so except for um now maybe uh 40 50
we solve all of them now so um
this is a quite different um benchmark
set so
in a certain sense i would maybe say um
yeah because these benchmarks were
picked in a certain way but i guess
some of the people who had to pick them
are in the audience
um so maybe you should really sort of
cut off here because here uh maybe this
this is a different
um different type of benchmarks at any
house i wanted to show that that we have
exactly the same trend except that the
uh
the things are more compact but that's
probably just due to
a smaller number of benchmarks like 292
versus 400.
yeah i mean may i comment on this uh
i think that there is also a big
difference is that some of the solvers
have
seen those benchmarks so all the solvers
and so they have been trained tuned and
which is not the case for
for the 2020. so that's absolutely
yeah i should i should point this out
that uh of course like all these solvers
here like since
uh 2013 are heavily tuned
on on these guys right so they have seen
them and they tried to improve them so
they
they've been running on the cluster for
a long time but here
these benchmarks are brand new and i
think like
there were like 100 use old ones but 300
new ones or something but
i'm i'm happy to be corrected here and
um and they are considered way harder
than than
than um indeed than in 2011.
and i guess the the variety of
benchmarks is just so much
uh more important currently than
10 years ago yes so so the yeah exactly
so
the organizers do the following so they
pick you have to print your own
benchmarks so that means you have to
always submit some interesting
benchmarks
and then they pick from each source at
most 20 and they don't even
always pick 20 so that and this is not
the case here for
for 2011.
okay um
then danielle because you're here so you
you tweeted two weeks ago
and well because i was busy i wrote oh i
cannot do this what you right here at
the bottom so
so he was uh announcing this talk here
danielle and uh
he said like i remember the service lima
come start nanoside picosat and more
and i've been like submitting to all
these competitions
and then daniel asked he would want to
see a cactus plot and then i answered
which is not on the slide
uh yeah well i will show you a cdf
because um
we kind of disagree whether cdf or
cactus blood is better
but then actually matthias was so nice
matthias flurry at postdoc in my group
was so nice to run
some uh uh of these servers actually
most of them
and i just finished one more run an hour
ago
um so i'll show you this on the next
slide
and uh here's one more thing i wanted to
show you so
in the middle it was another tweet where
um somebody was working on this conway
life and they tried to find sort of like
some sort of stable um or sort of
producing or
things which kind of work forever um
state machines in a sense
and uh adam gusher has
been doing this with the sass over so he
puts a thank you
to me because um he was only able to do
that with
with uh kisat in catechol um
okay so so this is the plot which
matthias
helped me to produce these are almost
all solvers
of mine and there's like um
um just a second it says my internet
is unstable but you can hear me right um
so
um um
i have a couple of solos i lost it seems
so i found them in my cd but i cannot
find the source code anymore
and most of them um i mean like i i
i claim actually all of them are really
written from scratch so i do this thing
that you
kind of throw things away and then start
from scratch of course the algorithm
are capped and then refined and then you
kind of concentrate on the
uh sort of minimalistic part you want
you need to achieve a certain effect
and you saw already limat here uh which
which won
one track in the competition in 2002 but
it's like
a little bit strange because they had a
uh at the end
uh a tie and then they used three
benchmarks to uh break the tie and ice
was
myself was solving one more benchmark
and the competitor so it was i was
winning kind of by one
one instance um yeah and then there's
some lots of
uh solvers like this such silver i i did
just for
this seminar for this uh boot camp um
so this is the latest uh this 4.17 is
the latest public version
in the meantime i played with adding
pre-processing to it but only variable
elimination
didn't and when i'd be able to release
it there will be something more
and you see from here to here also a
small jump
and of course the reason why such um
really leads all the other ones here is
because
uh it's kind of uh incorporates all the
the
lessons learned from keysight and
catechol in terms of what you need to
get
like a fast cdc loop uh and
um it's also highly configurable
documented
so so i urge you to to look at it so you
can also watch the other two talks
uh if you want to learn more more about
this sober
and then i expected a question here but
nobody asked the question
yeah yes yes so i mean so what was the
the big difference between nanoset and
picosat
because you see there is a huge
difference oh this is this
um our sub thing and and nano and also
reducing was not good in nano size so
these two silvers nano sat
and comb sat there comsa did not reduce
costs at all
yeah so and uh which is very funny
uh so if you would complain so so you
will if you will see that
grasp um has similar performances
um actually um
also had a inferior scheme into reducing
and also had another problem so you only
used one watch for learned clauses which
is of course not something you want to
want to do and then picosat was a big
step forward
and um yes
then cleanling was like such a sober
which was meant for sort of a summer
school
actually tutorial and
yeah and so on so i could explain more
about the the single ones if you want
and i have some more stuff so yeah and
just one more thing so which solvers are
running
uh local search on among those ones
in parallel to what or include local
search
in in addition to cdcl
so key set oh
oh i think we may have lost
no no i mean it's here oh here's the
screen chairs back okay good
yeah carmen you're muted yeah i was
kicked out
it said before my internet connection is
strange so i'm not sure
um anyhow uh so i we were talking about
uh local search right
yes so i was just asking how many of
of your solvers on this plot are using
local search
uh keysight this was exactly the point i
want to say here so there's this which
is a local
server and i put this on purpose here
and it solves more benchmarks than lima
and if you
uh go back here to this plot um oh here
i don't have it
but you see that lima was actually here
way above the solars which were like
from the
from last century and so it's had it's
easy to claim that
at least in 2020 and the same is true
but to a less extent here in
in in 2009 um that these
pure locals source so we can only so
satisfiable instances is
actually doing not bad right and that's
true to some some of the part of the
history i have on my slide
uh but uh yeah so these two are uh only
doing local search so such does not have
local search in it yet
so only these two guys and of course
this is a pure local search store
so armand
just um you mentioned a couple concepts
that i'm not sure what you meant and
maybe
others don't you mentioned the earlier
solvers didn't do very good clause
reduction
and then you've mentioned local search
several times as we just say a few
sentences on what those two
two concepts are yes so clause reduction
means that like
um so so in concept uh
it uh um i just learned classes and i
never
uh i always kept them forever and i
really me
i thought like this is good and uh but
then uh there was
a competition where um like comes had
lost
traumatic against other soldiers and
their main reason was because the other
soldiers eagerly
were throwing away clauses um and
and so i learned so throwing away
learning clauses which
are kind of not used this is the it's
called reduce
in in the source and yeah you could
think of
it as a cash rate so it's like the
learned clauses are a cache of the
search and
you cannot you don't want to keep um
even though you would have space
you don't want to keep these clauses
because they
they slow down the propagation that's
the whole source so you just throw them
away
and then the local search it's really um
yes the clause reduction is the same as
clause deletion
in other words so so reducing the
clause the learned clause database was
kind of the
i think original idea why people started
to use reduce as a term for that
um in this short word like restart
reviews right
we have one which is called rephasing so
that's why i like this so it's a work
which
describes this part of producing
non-cost database
and then local search really is a
classical local search algorithm
and um yeah this is what i expected so
we're running out of time so i would
have have a way of explaining it on the
blackboard because this is one of my
favorite things which happened in the
last 10 years
but maybe we'll do this only if if we
come back to this i would want to
explain
popsite which is a very cool idea and
very easy to explain and there was not
much talk about practical local search
uh in this whole seminar so that's why i
thought maybe that would be a way to
um to sneak this in but um and three
also this is a version of this pop song
right here
okay so it's a walk side very end
there's a question in the chat window if
you don't mind
uh masimulario asks are
any oh and any of the results are
obtained with something like
xor or cardinality detection question oh
yes
uh yeah lingering has this in it and
that's one of the reason why
um like for instance if you also saw the
talk by holger
and you paid attention to his way of
measuring a contribution that was
lingering actually highly ranked
and the reason for that is because
lingaling does pre-processing
with exo clauses and cardinality
constraint
and if you have sort of instances like
pitching hole or things like that
which can just be done by extracting for
instance cardinality constraint and then
doing some kind of elimination
or the same with with setting formulas
and you run lingening on it
then uh it will just instantly solve
these instances and that's of course
gives you a big
contribution but from a real practical
perspective it's kind of useless so none
of my new servers
is implemented but if i would implement
it i could solve like
more instances
okay all right
much more so so i have the same for 2009
so we discussed this
and i have less silver so i we ran out
of time in producing this so i
probably want to skip there unless
somebody wants to ask something here
and then i have two more slides and then
we could go to back to the
timeline plot so here's like things we
could
also discuss and but i again think we
should
focus on the timeline and come back to
this if if you're interested
okay so this is the the timeline i
usually show at the end of invited talk
and now
if i count right i have eight minutes to
to explain
uh these things um all right so here uh
we have
dp and dpl actually this should be put
probably a little bit earlier because
uh yeah i saw a technical report
where this research was described in
from 58
um but the eternal article appeared in
in 1960 and 1961 i think so
and uh yeah then you would ask what's
the next thing here
well this is where i was born and then
we have this starting point for this 50
years name of the seminar
rate like 71 was the the proof
from stephen cook and completeness and
completeness of sat
and this red line here this is like
where we are now
and you see already sort of like one
milestone here
well will should have the handbook of
the second edition of the handbook
in our hand this year the first one
appeared in 2009
here and in the middle there was knuth's
book
on on sat so this is kind of the i would
say
for me at least personally the the
biggest
milestone um yeah then let's let's look
here
at the first um part here so here i put
satan encoding this was of course used
in the proof complexity community not
really
in the practical um sat solving
community but
when we did this model checking at cmu
98 we worked on this um
actually people worked on bdds and
didn't know how to actually get the
formula into cnf
right and kind of from a practical side
it was extremely
important to know about this fact and we
just learned this um
sort of like uh through the theory uh
community
and uh yeah i remember uh talking to
some colleagues at cmu who said it's
impossible to do start solving to really
industrial benchmarks because you cannot
get a short formula to describe
something but it's not true with the
stating formula
for taking uh approach
all right then um yes wasn't the
original titan
encoding already in around where the
asterisk is by
by like you reciting yes i think this is
the wrong date you're right so
i think they're like they're citations
here right
1960 yeah yes 1968
yes also like close where i was born
okay could i i need to move this
thanks but anyhow so i wanted to point
this out this was really like early
and this extreme was extremely important
for for adopting here
uh when we wrote this bmc paper for deck
this was the main point explaining that
satan transformation right
and that let these people really apply
uh sat in the practical sense
yeah then there was a a like in aia
there was a big um
sort of concentration on on sat and in
the
um early 90s and um
it started already like 10 years earlier
maybe and
um this the focus back then was this
local search i was talking about
but people also started to look at look
ahead but like not that much and and one
important part there was they applied it
to to sub
uh they applied start for planning but
but i would say still sort of more in an
academic way so that the difference to
our
bmc application work here is of course
this has
had immediate consequences for applying
these things in in practice
um then there was a a big uh so they
used this uh gsat
method uh another method which appeared
later which is called walksat
uh also based on local search is uh uh
is better and
improved the these local search
formatically
and then of course you all know that uh
xiaomi silver and karen
came up with this cdcl which where in my
view the
the main part is this learning and the
implication
graph and in learning in a sense exactly
what we discussed before keeping those
clauses right so in this
cp community they also had this idea of
no good learning they had back jumping
they don't describe how they compute
these no goods right so
so but xiao and and darum were explicit
on using this implication graph and then
they also introduced
the first uip clause but you need this
reduction we talked
before actually in order to really make
this work
and that's kind of the chain big big big
game changer here
now our bmc work led to some more people
looking in at assad so like uh
shahrad malik and his group in princeton
um
actually use this to get a project on
trying to implement them
um uh starts over into
um into hardware and out of this project
came this
sort of the the this uh chaff and this
this results on v6 which was another big
breakthrough inside right it's
um yeah and then i i should put here
a mini sub which i think we simply
forgot it seems so the two mini site
authors here are um uh
responsible for it should be here uh for
uh really uh putting lots of new
insights into how to implement these uh
uh this ideas fast and in particular how
to do visits fast
and other things in the satso and
actually around the same time which is
also quite interesting from historical
perspective the satisfiability
module theory came around and it really
needs this idea of cdcl to really
make use of this sort of communicating
cdc uh
theory source and that's for many people
um one of the big improvements i was
also funny
um there was a big distinction between
sat and smt so people were careful to
say
this uses the use of smt solver and now
people use more and more uh actually
called even smt silver start solvers
which is also a pretty intriguing
question all right so uh here is like
bounded viable elimination which is the
first really
very powerful proof preprocessor and
still today probably is the most
important one
but in essence it's just the variant of
this odp
and but using in a slightly different
way right really using it as
as a pre-processing and bounding it
um yeah then uh two more things i wanted
to to explain so there's this popside
which is a very cool
local search variant of of walksat very
easy to explain if i would have more
time i would have
explained it but i think we're running
out of time then
uh phase saving was also a big idea and
this is
just which to which value should you
assign a variable
and this gives a really impressive
practical
improvements without really being really
complicated from a sort of um
implementation perspective it's like two
lines or three lines of code
and um yeah here
um uh is lbd or glucose
level which was invented by by jill and
and and this gave a new view on how to
uh you
how useful are they on courses so once
again so this
cdcl here compared to the previous cpu
work kept the learn classes
and now keeping all the learn clauses
you cannot because you will just run out
of
of of steaming propagation this was my
comp set now you need good ways to
remove courses and this was kind of the
big sort of improvement here was done by
my two french
colleagues in 2009
yeah then uh i want to maybe highlight
out
the improcessing i mentioned already
like in since 2013 all the winners of
the sub competition use in processing
which means you
you're really into leaf cdcl search in
pre-processing
but i want to point out here this part
which which
i think i'm sort of like as a sat um
person uh really proud of so this is
avatar is the technique
the vampire theorem proofer which is
kind of the world leader in
in philosophy improving uses to to
implement
first order resolution they actually
drive the whole resolution process by a
set server these days
and they even query sets always it's
actually very similar to how satsubas
are used in smt
so you can really claim that first out
of theorem proving the best solvers
there in particular in practical
application you suck at
it is the core and it goes further
because if you think about like what
do you do if you verify let's say an
operating system kernel
well you will probably do this in isabel
or in some other
like um higher order logic framework and
the biggest improvement probably in the
last 10 years in this domain
was to come to use the use of these
hammers and hammers are
are um sort of like techniques to take
this first order problem
and translate it abstract it to a say
first order or sat or
smt problem and then use a sats over in
any case
even if they would use a first order
theorem prover they would use a sad
solver to solve sort of higher order
uh logic uh problems and then from that
you would get either proof
or if if you try to find the content uh
example
yeah and then this brings me and i'm
running out of time one minute over time
but we still have like 15 minutes for
discussion so there's a couple of things
which
which are green and actually today i
remove this green thing here
for arithmetic solvers because we do
have a couple of papers we also
contributed
um to it uh on on really using sort of
an enterprise reasoning
that's what i mean here but also maybe
pseudo-boolean reasoning could be put
there
to improve the uh the the effectiveness
of sat solvers
and so so what's missing here that's why
i'm kind of was reluctant
uh to really put this here's is really
doing it on the cnf level that's
nobody has done yet so the only way uh
how we can do it is like this is what
lingaling does like extracting this
algebraic um information and then
running an arithmetic
solver on it also including many such
there like attempts in this this
direction
yeah here are things which which um
i think still need some work so um the
parallel part is
is not solved yet so doing sat on
parallel machines
from in on all levels is is unclear
maybe
uh we know what to do if we run a
portfolio so i mentioned this here
uh so maybe up to eight core 16 cores or
something
but having like 96 scores or
i don't know a thousand of course on
your traffic cards
or running this over in the cloud this
is really unclear
um we know how to do it for hard
combinatorical problems this is this
cube being conquered somehow
still partially manual this work the
splitting part
but sort of using cell solvers in a
massively parallel way and just for any
problem that's
unclear like for qbf maybe big
improvements we have also a new chapter
but we're still lacking a sort of killer
app so
sort of had killer apps like i claimed
the first one was our bmc
but there are other apps now of course
lots of applications of sat now
for qbf you don't have that on i claim
and i would be really happy to
to prove them wrong here um certain smt
everywhere so this is slowly actually
happening so if you're like uh
do submit jobs to the amazon cloud they
would um
schedule these with the cvc4
and would solve some constraints which
in turn
would use sub technology so uh maybe
these sub servers are slowly getting
anywhere so
and uh yeah so um
i would say we're looking forward to
more um
work on this and um yeah i i still think
the
the the history of sat so this
improvement is a
revolution which i put in the abstract
is actually continuing
and i don't see any slowdown we're
making progress every year both on
theory
and on the practical side okay
thanks so that that concludes the things
i wanted to say
thank you very much that was a very nice
talk i'll clap on behalf of everybody
and we have definitely some time for
questions so i hope everyone will
jump in with questions and so forth um
let's see yeah yes may i ask
uh so i mean so when we are back in 2002
and you have a chance to implement one
thing from 2021 in lima
what would it be
um well that's interesting um
well the face saving for sure i am not
sure like space saving only works
together with restarts i'm not sure
actually
um um no i think like the way how close
reduction done is extremely clever so
so so maybe i should mention this so so
this is restarting
and the gloss reduction so these are
things like which partially were solved
here
uh now i think i know how to do that so
of course like as i said it was
partially solved around the time so with
this lbd and also here with
phase saving right so but it took still
10 years to really find a way how to do
it
precisely and of course like maybe
somebody came up with an even better way
but um the current way how close
reduction you can read this up in my in
the source code function of such
uh this is what i would say is the the
the biggest uh improvement
uh i'm also not sure i forgot to mention
chansecos oswald i should really put
this here this happened in 2013 i think
like switching between fast and slow
restarts
and that's also very important yeah i
don't know
very very hard to say i would say it's
the the reduction
is doing reduction uh is probably the
most important because
if you can sort of remove like um
you see like the lbd allowed us to
remove uh instead of
um keeping the
sort of like a fraction of the learned
clauses
a fixed fraction because you had a
geometric increase of the
risk reduced schedule with this lbd we
were able to move
to an arithmetic one which essence means
you can after like 10 000
conflicts you only keep a square root of
10 000
crosses without losing efficiency and
this really improves
your solvers kind of quadratically if
you think about it right
thanks there's a question in the chat
window from
um from mate seuss
there seems to be a lack of
understanding how different techniques
interact why do you think this is the
case
too difficult to obvious too many
techniques
no it's a so so this is a good very good
question and matty knows this of course
uh but he doesn't do it this way so this
is why i throw away the sauce overs like
once in a while
because i think uh the only way to
figure that out is you only implement
some of the stuff you did before
and then figure out what's really sort
of the smallest uh
combination of things so so this just
happened actually to matthias and me
so we presented this target facing which
is
one of the parts of one of the reasons
for this um improvement last year
and uh this target phases we thought we
also need to randomly flip
the the the signs and also to um to
to flip it somewhere but this is really
not useful this is just
um not necessary and we only came to
this conclusion after implementing such
and in such it didn't make a difference
and then reported it back to catechol
and
and keysight so it's a very painful way
of figuring out what are the things to
kind of return kind of dependent and
which need to
need to be kept and which not okay
um see another question of the chat
window that valentin meyer is um
quote qbf lacking killer application
quote
isn't the application side waiting for
the solvers to be ready
slash mature to solve more than trivial
formulas
well the the issue is um well first of
all there's like a format problem so qbf
wasn't always considered as an extension
of
of satan so it worked on cnf but that's
not good for various reasons
so it's just because kind of in qvf
solutions and counter examples are kind
of
um kind of should be in the same format
right but if you move from a c in f
to its negation you get like not a c in
f anymore and
um this is one one way one thing i think
where the the sort of the community made
a mistake on kind of
just adopting cnf so um
now um these there are solvers and
technologies which work also on cnf
but my feeling is you would also need
some
sort of applications where you start off
with with a circuit or with
with the formula and and then use the
full power of of qbf that's my my belief
uh and we haven't seen uh examples like
that much
um i have some old like more than 10
years old paper where for instance in
the context of model checking where we
actually in 1998 we first tried to use
qbf servers for
model checking then failed and then did
this beams here right
um and there the we only have negative
results
and so maybe we need to just need a
different sort of application where it's
obvious to use qbf and this is the right
formalism
that's mine i think the solvers are
already but not like the
sort of the problems don't fit the input
format
interesting okay uh cool deep meal asks
uh in the chat window what about
non-cdcl based solvers
and also can you comment on non-cnf
representations
such as pb or xor pseudo boolean or xor
right oh um so first one would be
yeah we do of course this look ahead
thing and uh
yeah um of course i've been playing with
this for long
many times and this look ahead currently
is
most important for this hard
combinatorical problems and there we
will see more
um sort of mixed um things then
but if if could actually meant a
different sort of solving technology
like tb
solving and um
ilp solving for instance yes i totally
agree there should be sort of
more interaction and we saw this
actually in this house last half year
there is interaction between the groups
and um
[Music]
yeah and but but but maybe you see like
with these pb servers
uh and and also with the um
arithmetic servers um we always struggle
to get
get it back into the from the cnf into
the arithmetic problem and
and that might actually be sort of a
similar problem as in qbf maybe this is
not the right way to present the
problems
um um and of course we need proofs for
this
this is something i didn't discuss much
this is a big thing here in my slide
here i completely forgot to mention this
um like the last five years i would say
before the competition last year the
biggest thing i think inside
practical side that we have these proofs
like both for mathematical problems but
also sort of in practice
um and that's a big thing and
now when we go to this arithmetic
solvers or pp slowers how
what what we do with the proofs it's
unclear and we had some talks here
but like i would say we don't know
exactly where we're going
okay so armin can i ask you a question
yep so um
you mentioned that minisat played a very
important role for
for sat solver development and now i
mean looking at this slide you have this
plethora of different techniques like
phase saving and switching phases and
reduction techniques and lbd and whatnot
then it's a bit
intimidating so what what do you think
is a way forward are we waiting for like
a new simple clean unifying minisat-like
or should we i don't know embrace all
these techniques and just put some
machine learning on top to really
learn how to harness it without really
understanding what's going on or
like what would if you you know no but
if you were like to advise
some young people going into the field
like where do you think we should go
i mean there's this uh there are easy uh
uh things so so this uh um
but but you see like this phase-saving
is also something which is easy and um
i for sure tried this since also nicolas
in uh tried it
but you it only started to work if you
combine it with this rapid restart
it's completely strange in a certain
sense and right so the argument is if
you do this rapid restarts then
uh the phase saving helps you to avoid
like redundant work because you will go
into exactly the same
search corner again and
and you want to have this fast restarts
and the face saving to to order fine
short proofs for unsatisfiable form and
that's actually the interesting part
and i'm not sure whether they did this
actively
i don't think so actually um so they
didn't really
search for this like how can i get short
um unsight proofs
but this is the effect and um
yes in the paper by lauren and angel
uh the lbd paper it's it's also very
similar so they try to find the metric
like what
could allow you to predict with the
clauses are are useful and this is at
the very heart of this cdca so this is
not like some strange technique no this
is at the very heart as i try to explain
because
if you do cdcl and you learn you also
have to forget these clauses and the
good and
the best way we have now to do that
which gives you kind of as i said like a
reduction
uh a square root reduction in terms of
memory
uh that's this lbd and something else
like
which i don't want to go into now but
but this is
yes yeah i agree but just to
to to sort of
play the devil cybercat as it were or
you know if you look at
i understand that these chelsea oh
settings are the best ones with these
tiers and stuff but it's not like
you know a clean mini set like
impression i mean it's it seems like
it's very hacky and mysterious and this
is how you should do it and it just
works
last year's oh i wouldn't say it's
material so this is like
this is exactly the part what i wanted
to say so some of these came about and
also this transit oh thing by
by seeing some effect empirically right
but now if for instance you would go
into my latest solver
it's precisely explained and i claim
it's also not sort of like convoluted or
something it's completely clear what you
should do
but the way how it sort of appealed this
technique is different
i completely agree but this is probably
sort of the sort of like you do
empirical science to figure out like
what could
help rain
and what's the way forward like some you
know no i mean like
that's one issue of course the issue is
with all this uh practical word right so
people have this term like rocket
science right
uh so so you have all these uh
technology which build on top of each
other
and and of course like now finding
something new but
uh it's it's very difficult so i claim
this target phases is something new
right
and also the way to put this local
search in it
uh but of course to get to this point
you require maybe like 20 years like in
my case
or more clearly not just like the five
years of phd synthesis
to get to this point um so unless you
have of course
somebody who guides you in this
direction right
yeah i mean there's also one one related
point to this is of course the way how
we
actually uh uh review papers uh and
in this empirical domain right so in
order to get some of these
uh sort of improvements you know one it
has to be patient but one nice to
encourage people to
to go towards doing strange empirical
measurements right
okay any other short question maybe or
um i think we're probably done thank you
again for the talk this was very
interesting so
thank you and thank you
we're gonna take a